I know as well as anybody Bass Pro uh is
a lot of fun and sometimes you know you
go to Bass Pro and look you just go a
little nuts you get you get a little
wild in the Bass
[Music]
Pro we've all been there but but usually
that means that you just buy a lot more
fishing tackle than you were originally
planning on buying disrobing and jumping
in the aquarium should not be a part of
that and that's the thing that for me to
see man defile the sanctity of the Bass
Pro fish tank is very upsetting so for
Bass Pro fans this is our January 6th I
mean this is the day that will live in
infamy for us um I'll never be able to
look at a Bass Pro aquarium the same way
again I'll always have that image seared
in my mind